are the silver honors go to tottenham
Xavi for Parvana which was made at the
zurich University of the Arts in
Switzerland wow I really didn't expect
that sorry I have to read something
first I will I really want to take the
ACT Academy for this awesome price it
was amazing week and we really really
had fun with all those winners and all
those great people I would also like to
thank my awesome crew who held together
in spite of the given circumstances on
set we shout in February 2012 and it was
the coldest month in about 150 years
yeah 15 degrees below Celsius yeah but
we still had a lot of fun so great coup
I would especially like to thank the
producer Stefan eichenberger with your
presence and ambition you were able to
grant all of our wishes Stefan Dukes are
symptomatic refer for the great picture
and stamina in spite of difficult times
and hannah's rittiman our editor for his
great editing you're very talented and
it's very pleasant working with you you
guys really did a great job thank you
thank you to all my actors especially
Nisa she's over there i canna
and also the second one sherry graph two
great talented actors who truly did
their best for this movie nisa you
brought the character of parvaneh to
life I like to thank my family my
parents for always packing me up and for
supporting my decision to make movies
though they know how difficult it is to
survive in the art industry thank you to
my brother and my cousin for the
everlasting or for yer unwell made
suggestions when cousin is also here
thank you to my boyfriend for his love
and support and for bearing with me when
I'm sometimes about to go crazy I would
also like to thank the Zurich University
of the Arts along with all the
professors and mentors during the entire
production a special thanks to Barbara
kucha for her guidance during the
writing process of the script for the
more a big thank you to Swiss radio and
television the banner film for the room
and all other entities that made it
financially possible to realize this
movie thank you very much